bueno uno de los privilegios que uno
tiene a la hora de elegir su carrera
sobre todo cuando hace una carrera de
ciencias como la mía como ciencias
físicas es que se presupone que uno
tiene que ser inteligente bueno pues a
mí ni siquiera me pasó eso fue algo
desastroso porque aunque parecía que iba
tener esa tendencia de mira qué tío más
visto tuve una novia que me dijo mira tú
es que eres muy listo para las
ecuaciones pero muy tonto para el recado
y eso se me quedó toda la vida diciendo
vaya por dios es que ni siquiera por
este camino puedo bueno pues después de
muchos años de viajar por diferentes
laboratorios de volver a españa justo
empecé a trabajar con la inteligencia
artificial y en ese momento volvió otra
vez esa frase que no habían dicho pero
totalmente al revés y me di cuenta que
la inteligencia artificial siempre que
trabajaba con ella era como pero es que
de verdad tú eres lista para el recado
pero tonta para las ecuaciones y pasó
totalmente al revés y cómo es eso pues
bueno os voy a explicar aquí justamente
por qué bueno partamos de la base y de
intentar comprender qué es la
inteligencia la inteligencia es algo que
todo el mundo habla pero nadie sabe
perfectamente definir de hecho había un
tipo
en el que intentó definir ocho tipos de
inteligencia y eso al final realmente es
engorroso porque realmente para mí no
solamente son elementos prácticos de la
vida elementos en los que uno empieza a
trabajar y se cree que es inteligente
vale entonces yo intenté buscar y
siempre intentando aumentar un poquito
encontré con una solución para mí la
inteligencia es algo mucho más sencillo
para mí una persona inteligente es una
persona que es capaz de hacer fácil lo
difícil es eso tan llanamente entonces
cuando uno es inteligente analíticamente
es porque es capaz de [ __ ] un problema
matemático que es complicado y hacerlo
fácilmente cuando una persona es
inteligente emocionalmente es porque
algo tan difícil como tener amigos tener
relaciones lo hace una manera fácil
cuando una persona es lingüísticamente
inteligente es porque tiene el don de la
palabra sabe manejar bueno pues entonces
partiendo de esa base partiendo de esa
base de la inteligencia entonces ya
empecé a razonar
y me di cuenta de una cosa que es que el
tiempo que necesita la inteligencia para
madurar porque la inteligencia también
necesita de datos pero porque como es
eso que nosotros necesitamos datos pues
si cogemos realmente la evolución del
ser humano el ser humano ha evolucionado
en los últimos años pues bueno el primer
primate fue hace 65 millones de años y
desde los 65 millones de años hasta
ahora realmente en nuestro cerebro ha
ido evolucionando evolucionando
evolucionar y de repente en un pispás
tuvo esa evolución se ha colapsado y no
se transforma el mundo gracias a la
inteligencia pero por qué porque es que
no nos damos ni cuenta de realmente todo
el tiempo yo a mí me gusta me gusta
[ __ ] el calendario de carl sagan que
algunos a lo mejor conocen carl sagan
era un científico algún divulgador
americano que era premio pulitzer y que
hizo
en la televisión una serie que se llama
post motín el cual puso un calendario en
donde era el calendario de todo el
universo digamos de todo el tiempo que
había transcurrido en donde el 1 de
enero empezaba el big-bang y el 31 de
diciembre era el tiempo que tenemos hoy
en día bueno pues el primer organismo
pluricelular había nacido en noviembre y
el primer primate había nacido el 31 de
diciembre a las 10 y 45 de la mañana
bueno pues nosotros si consideramos así
las pirámides de egipto habían sido las
23 horas y 50 segundos y cristóbal colón
a las 23 horas 59 segundos por lo tanto
en un segundo desde cristóbal colón'
hemos evolucionado y transformado toda
la tierra en base a la inteligencia y
por qué porque la inteligencia además de
tener esa capacidad increíble de
transformar necesitaba datos es decir
que el hombre ha ido acumulando datos
hasta que ha tenido esa explosión y de
repente ahora aparece otro tipo de
inteligencia que es la inteligencia
artificial en la cual cambia
absolutamente todos nuestros paradigmas
porque porque es mucho más rápida si
nosotros repente en los últimos 100 años
hemos dado la vuelta a la tierra
bien te aparece algo que es muchísimo
más rápido bueno pues vamos a restar un
poquito más en detalle qué es la
inteligencia artificial pues la
inteligencia artificial realmente es la
capacidad que tenemos o por lo menos
como lo definió mccarthy es la intención
que tenemos que intentar hacer máquinas
que repliquen el pensamiento humano de
ver realmente al final no son máquinas
son todo tipo de técnicas todo tipo de
algoritmos todo tipo de elementos que
intentan hacer que las máquinas hagan el
trabajo el ser humano es decir que
cuando el ser humano piense y desarrolla
algo esas máquinas pueden hacerlo por él
bueno realmente al final lo que cogemos
es una cantidad ingente de datos y los
manipulamos con una serie de reglas para
obtener
bueno esto es ya de una manera de verlo
un tanto simplón a algo que si me
cogiera a alguien de los que el trabajo
de día me da es que estás desvariando no
pero es más o menos así de hecho está me
diría me diría que es que necesitas
datos iniciales hay gente que pone
algoritmos directamente con esos
algoritmos directamente bueno sacan
resultados finales bueno tampoco es
verdad tienes por ejemplo alfa goal fago
es una máquina que el señor google en el
cual realmente lo que hicieron es
intentar competir contra el campeón del
mundo de lo que es una especie de
ajedrez asiático y idearon una máquina
que poniéndoles solamente las reglas de
juego y él mismo empezó a jugar contra
sí mismo en tres meses había adquirido
todo el conocimiento y ganó al campeón
del mundo bueno pues esta es la primera
versión la segunda versión tardó sólo
tres días en tres días poniendo en las
reglas directamente pim pam pum pum pum
y le gana al tipo es increíble es
increíble como lo hace como abrace bueno
pues todas estas técnicas que son más en
long y blooming
anales de todo ese tipo de algoritmos
que uno hace lo que necesita es
muchísimos datos muchísimos muchísimos
datos y ni siquiera en el alfa bon que
lo hayan puesto desde el principio sin
datos el mismo empezó a crear partidas y
se acumuló los datos es lo mismo que ha
sucedido con la humanidad la humanidad
tiene una inteligencia pero le faltaba
lo mejor meter esos datos eso que
nosotros llamamos conocimiento hemos ido
adquiriendo conocimiento conocimiento
conocimiento hasta que en un momento
dado todo ese conocimiento ha
explosionado y hemos transformado la
tierra hasta ese momento pero la
inteligencia estaba faltaba el
conocimiento igual que las máquinas
necesitan los datos y después necesitan
los algoritmos pues de esa misma manera
ha pasado y de esa misma manera es lo
que está ocurriendo hoy en hoy en día
ejemplos ejemplos por ejemplo hoy en día
todo lo que es la fotografía digamos los
algoritmos de detección fotográfica
automatizados es decir que hoy en día
cogemos una fotografía una persona y
podemos saber quién es cómo se hace pues
básicamente se coge la fotografía se
transforma todo en datos numéricos y
esos datos muy ricos con un análisis
matemático encontrar los patrones
es ahí en donde nosotros tenemos que
meternos investigar es decir en contra
de ese análisis matemático para
encontrar más patrones ese análisis que
es básicamente un análisis estadístico y
en con esos patrones ya podemos después
encontrar otras fotografías digamos
cogemos otras fotografías que tengan los
mismos patrones y que
probabilísticamente sean iguales y eso
lo hacemos con máquinas muy muy rápidas
y podemos encarar encontrar fotografías
y deducir qué cosas es la que vendía por
ejemplo hay otra cosa que hoy en día es
increíble que es la detección una cosa
se llama n en el eje que es decir la
generación automática del lenguaje somos
capaces de dar una tabla excel sólo con
datos
y que el ordenador nos vean al lado un
resumen escrito de qué significan esos
datos es decir que nosotros por ejemplo
quiero hacer un resumen de lo que ha
pasado en la liga le doy todo el resumen
de los partidos con una serie de
actuación me dice en la crónica del
partido del aller ha automatizado todo
cómo hago eso bueno pues lo hacemos de
una manera metemos millones y millones
de informes asociados a datos
la máquina empieza a aprender a aprender
a aprender a aprender y cada vez que
encuentra va esos patrones empieza a
escribir más o menos como hubiera
escrito antes
empieza con relacionarlos y acabamos
sacando un informe muy parecido al que
teníamos
es increíble pero claro ahí necesito
muchísimos datos y sobre todo la
capacidad de poder
digamos hacer esos patrones hacer esas
reglas hacer esos elementos que hacen
que pueda conectar los datos con un
elemento final pero a veces eso no
solamente es lo bueno por ejemplo hace
poco ha habido una máquina que ha ganado
a los campeones del mundo de poker y el
poker es el típico juego como puede ser
el go en donde realmente lo que importa
es un estudio estadístico digamos
probabilístico en el porque realmente el
buen jugador teques a ver las
posibilidades de cada mano y cómo tiene
que jugar pero por otro lado
el po que hay que saber intuir y hay que
también engañar y entonces ahí es en
donde se encontraban siempre con un
problema que es que la máquina no sabía
intuir y no sabía engañar bueno pues han
sido capaces de crear sus rutinas
también para el engaño de manera que ha
ganado a los jugadores de poker pero al
fin y al cabo eso para mí no es engaño
porque esas subrutinas el engaño es
natural es algo que aparece es algo que
intuyes no puede de repente programarse
el engaño pero ellos no han programado
por lo tanto ese engaño la persona que
sabe cómo lo ha programado no le podrá
engañar no es un engaño natural entonces
realmente todo esto que estoy explicando
es inteligencia no es inteligencia
partamos de la base de qué es la
inteligencia para nosotros es decir
cuando somos pequeñitos y nos empiezan a
enseñar qué hacemos pues somos pequeños
nos dicen aprender aprender de la
lección y después aprende de una serie
de reglas y cuando tienes que hacer un
examen tienes que aplicar un poquito
esas reglas a los elementos que tienes
de conocimiento para sacar yo me acuerdo
cuando estaba en el liceo que siempre
teníamos una estructura muy férrea del
aprendizaje tesis antítesis síntesis
teníamos que tener al principio que es
la parte a favor la parte en contra de
hacer una síntesis de todo era una
estructura muy muy cerrada eso se puede
programar lo puedes hacer exactamente
igual que enseñar a una persona de hecho
se está haciendo entonces porque eso no
podemos crear máquinas exactamente igual
que nosotros y que hagan exactamente lo
mismo porque no podemos por una sencilla
razón porque nos falta un elemento un
elemento que a diario no se sabe como
allá y que yo creo que va a ser la
diferencia que es la imaginación
esa imaginación es lo que digamos nos
saca a nosotros del apuro de competir
contra las máquinas qué es la
imaginación la imaginación es justamente
saltarse las reglas decir que cuando hay
un fallo no es un fallo eso es algo
bueno y darle la vuelta a la tortilla es
[ __ ] un elemento que sea erróneo y
hacerlo bueno es [ __ ] una regla que me
han dicho por aquí no vayas pues por
aquí que voy y eso es lo que hace que el
mundo evolucione todo ha evolucionado
gracias al error cuando ha habido
errores ha habido evolución si no hay
errores no evolucionamos si el código
genético no se rompe en un momento dado
y no tenemos digamos saltos en esa
transformación del código es cuando no
tenemos evolución y en cambio el hombre
no sabe programar errores sabe programar
para hacerlo bien pero no sé programar
para hacer errores por lo tanto no puede
hacer una máquina que evolucione tendrá
lo que tendrá tendrá lo que nosotros le
digamos que tenga que tener a día de hoy
pero esa evolución viene solo dado por
el error
cerros o ese cambio de mentalidad yo no
puedo decirle oye si has hecho algo malo
empieza a pensar que a lo mejor eso que
has hecho malo puede ser bueno que es lo
que hacemos nosotros cuando a vez que
tenemos algo malo le damos la vuelta
intentamos mejorar pero ese informe
valentín se intenta hacer es mucho más
complejo es mucho más complejo por lo
tanto yo creo que ahí está justamente el
paradigma de lo que nos encontramos
encontramos ante qué máquinas que son
capaces de hacer todas las tareas
rutinarias a una velocidad
extremadamente rápida extremadamente
eficiente pero que no son capaces de
hacer otras cosas novedosas entonces ahí
nos encontramos nosotros en esta
situación social y en esta situación
social vamos a tener que convivir vamos
a tener que convivir nos vamos a tener
que transformar totalmente no nos
podemos quedar aquí hoy en día la
compañía que más se está creciendo de
seguros en eeuu una semana de monet que
es una compañía no de todo está
automatizado tú coges tu móvil te hacen
digamos con la foto te recogen y
directamente el colocar la entidad te
hacen todos los seguros a medida no
tienes que tratar con ninguna máquina
todos son algoritmos
no hay nadie que piense absolutamente
todo lo hacen automatizado hasta después
los partes tú tienes un parte del coche
le sacas una foto él mira más o menos y
te dice directamente en ese momento lo
que te va a costar la reparación porque
el 8 todo automatizado es decir todos
los procesos son automatizados entonces
en donde entra el humano aquí en donde
cabe el humano aquí no cabe en ningún
lado porque realmente estamos quitando
la única manera que nosotros tenemos de
en los próximos años de competir es
aportando aportando porque somos capaces
de equivocarnos porque somos capaces de
aprender cosas nuevas
somos capaces de realmente llegar donde
no llegan las máquinas porque las
máquinas cuando las programas al final
van a hacer lo que tú digas y esa
digamos tendencia hoy en día por ejemplo
que hay como que las máquinas nos van a
comer las máquinas nos van a dictaminar
yo por lo menos pienso que hay un límite
y ese límite justamente es el mismo
límite que ha quedado con todas las
tecnologías yo había una cosa que me
contaba mi abuelo que siempre me parecía
increíble mi abuelo
que nació a finales del siglo 19 siempre
decía que durante su vida había pasado
de que el hombre no volaba a que había
llegado a la luna o sea es un cambio
dramático es increíble pero de la luna
no hemos pasado porque la tecnología
tiene un límite y para mí la
inteligencia artificial tiene ese límite
ese límite que es justamente el poder
darles digamos
una especie de sensibilidad a la máquina
una especie de justamente de elemento
que tenemos los humanos y que ellos no
han fuertemente por todo eso al final y
retomando lo desde el principio
justamente tengo tengo tengo la suerte
tengo la suerte de que soy listo para
las ecuaciones y no tanto para el recado
y tanto para el récord porque porque yo
no quiero ser el recadero yo soy el que
haga las ecuaciones las ecuaciones
necesitas digamos ese elemento que
tenemos los humanos para hacer los
recados están las máquinas y gracias a
dios gracias a dios como
me decían desde el principio soy listo
para las ecuaciones pero muy tonto para
el recado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]